ghost in the shell' to innocence was
once again directed by Mamoru Oshii and
was technically the sequel to ghost in
the show despite the fact that he
doesn't necessarily view it that way
come on it's the sequel and this film
follows Bato and togusa as they team up
on an investigation as they try to
figure out why this murderous sex doll
has decided to slaughter her owner my
first encounter with this film was when
I saw the DVD of it in Blockbuster I
snatched that thing up I was so excited
I ran home I remember putting it in the
DVD player discovering there was no
English dub available so that
disappointed a lot of people but I was
like okay I'll watch the subtitle track
I put on the subtitle track and not only
did we get text for dialogue we got text
like footsteps and door opens and
helicopter approaches that's right the
original subtitle track for the first
release of Ghost Michelle to innocence
in America was simply closed captions
what the hell did you say
so that was probably the worst thing
ever that could have happened to this
film in America and this film has had a
long history of licensing errors in wars
between various companies the version
that I have of it is the Bandai blu-ray
that has an English dub that has the
corrected subtitles that thing is out of
print because as a lot of you know
Bandai stopped
localizing anime in America so that
blu-ray right there is actually the
rarest blu-ray that I own it's so weird
this is ghosts Michelle - why isn't this
more readily available there's a great
video on YouTube that went into the
licensing war that went on with this
movie I'm just going to link that in the
description below it's by a youtuber
called Bennett the sage he has a really
cool anime segment called anime
abandoned so this film came out nine
years after the first one and it was the
first anime film to ever be nominated
for the poem at Cannes Film Festival
even more so than the first film this
used a melding of digital and
traditional cel animation it's not as
seamless as the original and I notice it
a lot here it became a bit of a
distraction
oh she was given a bigger budget on this
film it's also about 20 minutes longer
than the original so clearly he tried to
do different things with technology and
we're in the fur
ghost in the shell' the digital
animation took a backseat to the
traditional cel animation here at times
it seems like it's taking over entire
sequences and I remember when I rented
this from Blockbuster and watched that
very shitty release of a DVD on a normal
CRT tube television even back then I was
like this is kind of noticeable I'm not
sure if this works and this is something
that became even more apparent when I
watched it on that 1080p blu-ray because
the older traditional cel animation
looks really good in HD and works really
well in high-definition
but those older rendered computer
graphics from the early 2000s don't
transfer well to HD and you can really
tell so pushing the licensing issues
aside and the not-so-great computer
animation aside how is this film I
actually really enjoy it and the reason
I really like ghost in the shell' -
despite the fact that I don't like it as
much as the first is because this film
does a lot more with its characters than
the original did the first ghost in the
shell' is a very short contained quick
film without a scene that feels
misplaced ghost in the shell' - is as
I've said 20 minutes longer and it has
more opportunities to flesh out the
characters of Botto and togusa we get to
see batos home life in this movie we
learn a little bit more about what he
feels his connection with the major as
she disappeared into the net somewhere
in the first film we learn a tad bit
more about togusa and his family life
and so we get to understand our
protagonists more we get more of an
opportunity to build up character in
this movie
togusa here is clearly the most human
character because his reactions to
things are sort of like us as the
audience he is that audience character
there's a scene early on in the movie
when they're investigating this murder
where he's talking to an Android woman
and she is just waxing philosophical and
going on and on and on and on and he's
like I have no idea what you're talking
about the dolls are not surrogates in
place of real babies the girls are not
practicing child rearing at all it may
just be that playing with the doll
happens to be similar to raising
children
the hell are you talking about so me as
an audience member I kind of zero in on
toga stuff for a lot of scenes in this
movie be like yes help me understand
what's going on that was at least how I
felt for the first two times I've
watched this movie I've seen it three
times now and I have a complete
understanding of everything that goes on
in this film because despite the fact
that ghost in the shell' is a very
challenging movie innocence is far more
so the first half of this film is
surprisingly traditional it's basically
just a police procedural with Bato and
togusa investigating these murders that
are taking place and I like police
procedurals movies like zodiac or seven
I really like watching people
investigate crime and having it feel
pulpy and entertaining and this film
really captures that in the first half
in the second half though right after a
very long parade sequence the film takes
a deciding Li different turn where our
characters get lost in a strange maze
that's not entirely real and then we get
a gigantic action sequence that is
beautifully animated by the way on a
ship where all these dolls are coming to
life and everything's really exciting
but I remember the first time I saw this
movie thinking is it the terrible closed
captioning that's making me not be able
to understand what's going on or is this
just a really confusing movie this is
one of those rare movies similar to the
first one where you really have to pay
attention to every line of dialogue
every single one and that can be hard
because this film doesn't give our
characters too much time to pause in
between saying very important things
listen I want to get something straight
before we go what is it we're only gonna
question them right do you like the
Yakuza no I hate them so do i but we're
just asking questions right like I said
you don't need to be a Yakuza yeah to go
visit the Yakuza but you also said we're
going to need weapons this to me is an
animation error that I often find in
anime films at least when they transfer
over to dubs because in the English
language you're trying to catch up with
everything that was just said in the
Japanese language and so they have to
kind of spout out a lot of really
important things really fast but then
there's not that pause that seems needed
in between conversations for a motion to
seep into the conversation or
frustration I've noticed that a lot of
animators in Japanese anime have a hard
I'm allowing conversations to feel a
little more realistic and so innocence
does suffer in that respect because you
have to pay attention to every word as I
said and sometimes it all just gets
thrown out there you have to be like
wait rewind okay okay I got it now this
film came out in that strange time
period where the MPAA had no idea how to
rate anime films Cowboy Bebop the movie
for whatever reason is rated R because
of a few bloody moments but ghost in the
shell' to innocence a movie about
murdering rampaging sex dolls is pg-13
okay I think what I love the most about
innocence is that it wisely does not try
to one-up the first film it steps back
and smartly realizes that that's going
to be a very difficult task and so what
we got was a very different movie a film
that really stands on its own that is
far more traditional than the first film
but requires a lot of thought and
repeated viewings to fully appreciate
the similar line that flows between the
first film and this film is what
inherently makes us human can a robotic
life-form or in this case a doll be
considered human if you insert human
thoughts into an artificial thing is it
human now and just like the first film
our characters stand around in rooms and
quote the Bible and other forms of
literature and it's meant to make us
think and it does the first few times
you can kind of watch it and think man
this is just a bunch of pretentious crap
and it's easy to do that in a film like
this but once you really latch on to the
message that mam ruh-oh she is giving us
in this film and you discover that he's
really trying to say that everyone is
equal in some form or the other and that
if you exploit the tendency to want to
control humanity or artificial
intelligence that's where things are
going to get messy
he has since stated in interviews that
that was his primary goal with this film
the message he was trying to get across
and well it doesn't always come through
in the film I appreciate this movie for
its stunning traditional animation the
combination though with CG animation for
me personally did not work as well in
this movie but I like the characters I
like the fact that Votto and togusa
get more time in this film to become
more fleshed out people I like the fact
that this film is really trippy towards
the last half it asks you to really use
your brain and think about what you just
saw and it does test your patience
that's rare in live-action filmmaking
this is a diamond in the rough when it
comes to animation a film that actually
makes you think I'm going to give ghost
in the shell' to innocence of B+ no it's
not as culturally impactful as that
first film but I think wisely they
didn't even try to one-up it so the new
ghost in the shell' movie is coming out
very soon let's all hope it's good thank
you guys so much for watching and if you
liked this you can click right here and
get stuff mine eyes
[Applause]
[Music]
you